[Musica]
non so se oggi in realtà inizio io
perché sta venendo in questo momento
lorenzo attendervi ad isola mette dentro
di lorenzo mi chiamo luca marchi fra i
capi di cui dovrebbe arrivare a momenti
forse tu a tutti direi che possiamo
andare e tra l'altro non l'ho detto max
trend a prendermi con la macchina è la
prima volta che lo vedo quindi saranno
della action nella politica in cattivi
sistemato a ron è incredibile l'agente
di sorpassare su si stavano intona speck
e pastori cioccolato è a posto ma visto
che professionalità oppure cose non sono
anche troppe era una specie di cosa per
tenerla camera che non ho quindi al
manfrotto tipo confronto dei poveri è un
marrone marotta nella macchina del fango
è il primo di euro se il prima registra
meno male che se non ci fosse stato
questo uomo e non avrei fatto nella mia
vita per amore della mai trovate sarà
tutto storto non importa di riviste mai
visti di video fanno schifo fa chi è
troppo grande è iniziato il grandangolo
sarà il grande angolo allora questa è
una di grosse l'unica cosa è bellissima
secondo me ma l'unica cosa su v.le
fisica è questa l'altra schifo ma
ragazzi
il discorso è difficile madonna 6
milioni giampiero licenziato
ma io non sono ne vedo poi giampiero più
bello di ca sta montando un saluto a
giampiero che monta questo video mi
voglio licenziare ciao
ma ecco che volevo dirvi la difficoltà
di guidare non è tanto la strada e la
gente che mi mette ansia la gente mette
ansia di vita adesso prosegue inseguire
una tattica seconda nota viking c'è una
youtuber aveva detto che lei per non
farsi rompere le palle con di guida
mette dietro la scritta no bimbo aborto
che si fa col clacson perché siamo
svegli albino un bambino ma ti prego i
ragazzi siamo qua non puoi andare però
giovani familiare milan elemento torino
marittima dove vado sempre a destra va a
destra no di rito il ragazzo nel record
a parcheggiare sta segnando la macchina
che clip sul calcio d'angolo di voi
perché sennò che ti league e sono stati
andiamo avanti ma è bellissimo con
questo sono casi che abbiamo scelto
apposta dalla rai metti la macchia non
dritta un po introverso così fai anche
tipo con le pubblicità tantissimo
[Musica]
qual è la sensazione di guidare come non
ci sono le prostitute cui rubare i soldi
ma non penso ascolta ma adesso attiva i
tergicristalli e ancora attivato per
rimetterci cristalli mi raccomando
attive tergicristalli e il cazzone
storico è stato visto fare
limitandoci ogni giacomo bravo rischia
subito di giurato pensato veramente da
ogni giorno ma se questa strada è possa
far iniziare una stanza io mi inverso
inferiore
[Applauso]
da niente morello ero io volevo far
tenere con l'avvocato bravo è stato
molto fanny con la supercar ora
superbolide metterla lì se non proprio
in quel punto una domanda da fare
hai la patente è in modo entrambi come
si non so come si mette può succedere
non riuscivo mai più guida madonna di
pronto volontà madonna mi guardava
avanti 20 fi questa cosa siamo abbiamo
perso il tutto cofano tutti gli mette la
sua destra
io c'è una paura di quello che stai
facendo invece no bravi ordine
scherzando sembrava che pizzo calabro
[Musica]